- Welcome back everybody.
We've got Wilmer Valderrama with us.
Give it up.
(audience cheers and applauds)
We've all loved Wilmer in
"NCIS" in recent years,
but before that,
we loved him as Fez in "That '70s Show"
and he still fits into
his costume. Shut up.
(Wilmer laughs)
To celebrate then and now,
here's a throwback game.
This is "That '70s Song".
(upbeat pop music)
♪ That '70's song ♪
(audience applauds)
♪ Song ♪
Lord, you wanna help us with this?
(majestic music)
- [Lord] I certainly do Kelly.
How you doing down there?
- (laughs) We're doing great.
- [Lord] You like that?
That was one heck of
an entrance, wasn't it?
- It was.
- [Lord] I almost said hell.
Anyway.
(Kelly and audience laughs)
- [Lord] Now here's the
skinny on today's game, y'all.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Lord] I'm gonna give you a clue
that leads to a song from the 1970s.
Now, if you know the title or the artist
you're gonna hit your button
and you're gonna answer.
Steals are allowed if you're wrong.
- Okay.
- [Lord] Now, Wilmer, you
playing to win a prize
for your side of the audience.
(audience claps and cheers)
And Kelly, you playing for the other side.
- Yeah. I'm not feeling
confident, but I'm...
- I just wanna make a quick announcement.
I was born in 1980.
- I was born in '82.
(audience laughs)
'82.
- [Wilmer] Okay.
- So we might both fail together.
(Kelly and Wilmer laugh)
- [Lord] Okay, okay
Can you dig it? Let's boogie.
Here we go. Here's your first one.
- Okay.
- [Lord] What was that '70s
song in which the singer
and her backing vocalist
had to catch a locomotive
to the Peach State late at night?
(buzzer dings)
- Locomotion.
- [Kelly] Nope.
(buzzer buzzes)
- [Lord] It is not locomotion.
(audience groan)
- Is it-
- [Lord] Now, Kelly, you can steal here.
♪ Leaving on a jet plane ♪
No?
- [Lord] They had to take
a locomotive of some sort
at midnight, down south.
♪ Midnight train to Georgia. ♪
- [Wilmer] Yeah.
(buzzer dings)
- [Lord] That is correct.
- Oh that is the one I meant.
It is midnight train to Georgia.
(audience cheers)
- Oh I thought...
That's the one I meant.
- [Lord] You got it.
That's what you meant.
I knew that's what you meant.
- I'm sorry,
that was Gladys Knight
And The Pips before, yeah.
- [Lord] It was Gladys Knight
And The Pips. You got it.
- Did they have planes in the seventies?
- Yeah, yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
- Sorry, I wasn't born.
- [Lord] Yes, they did Wilmer.
- Such a baby.
(audience laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
- We're so young.
- So young.
- [Lord] Oh, that was groovy.
All right, here's your next one now.
What was that '70s song
in which the singer
had a bullfrog friend named Jeremiah?
(buzzer dings)
♪ Jeremiah was a bullfrog ♪
(imitates guitar strumming)
(buzzer buzzes)
- [Lord] That wasn't actually the name
of the song, unfortunately.
(audience laughs)
♪ Na na na was it had ♪
♪ But he always had the one ♪
- [Lord] You can keep singing
it, but you still didn't-
♪ Joy to the world ♪
- Jeremiah?
♪ All the boys and girls. ♪
♪ Joy to the people and the... ♪
(buzzer buzzes)
- [Lord] It's not Jeremiah.
I'm sorry, Wilmer, I'm sorry.
But Kelly-
- [Kelly] Is it "Joy to the World"?
- [Lord] You did do it after the fact.
It was "Joy to the World"
by Three Dog Night.
- [Wilmer] Ah!
(audience cheers)
- My mom liked Three Dog Night.
- [Lord] It was-
- [Kelly] That's how I knew that one.
- [Lord] "Joy to the World".
- I just knew that. I had to sing it.
- [Lord] Okay, here's your next one.
What was that '70s song
in which the singer was just a poor boy
from a poor family asking to
be spared from a monstrous-
(buzzer dings)
♪ I'm just a poor boy ♪
- It's Queen.
♪ Of a family ♪
♪ Duh duh duh duh duh ♪
♪ Thunder very frightening ♪
♪ Woo Galileo ♪
♪ Galileo ♪
♪ Me no no no ♪
♪ Magnifico ♪
- I mean she should
just lose for that one.
(audience laughs)
- Um, "Bohemian Rhapsody"!
(buzzer dings)
- [Lord] It is "Bohemian Rhapsody".
(audience cheers)
- [Lord] I really enjoyed
watching you do that.
(audience laughs)
You could just do that for a half hour.
That was something.
- I have to sing them.
I can't, I dunno the title. (laughs)
- [Lord] We should just do an hour special
where you act out every
Queen song just like that.
(audience laughs)
- [Lord] You don't exactly sing it.
You kind of mouth it
and flail your arms around
like a crazy person.
- I like, I never wanna
see that footage. (laughs)
- [Lord] Thunderbolt and lightening,
very, very frightening.
Hey, that's me.
Okay.
(audience laughs)
Here's your next question.
- Oh man, I'm sorry.
- [Lord] What was that '70s song in which
at first the singer was scared,
some might say petrified.
(buzzer dings)
♪ First I was afraid, I was petrified ♪
♪ Duh duh duh ♪
Gloria. Gloria Gaynor.
I will survive.
- [Wilmer] "I Will Survive".
(buzzer dings)
- [Lord] "I Will Survive".
(audience applauds)
- [Kelly] I'm killing it!
Who knew I knew '70s music?
- [Wilmer] Who gets the point though?
This is the twist.
- [Lord] Kelly is crushing it.
- Get that wheel back.
(suspenseful music)
- [Lord] Oh oh.
- What does that mean?
- [Lord] That very over
the top sound means
it is our last question.
- What?
- [Lord] And this one is
worth double the points.
So, Wilmer, this is it, man,
you could bring it back right here.
- Oh yeah, great
- [Kelly] Oh man, okay.
- [Lord] Pay close attention.
(audience applauds)
- [Lord] Everybody-
(audience cheers)
See they rooting for you.
Okay, here's your question.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Lord] What was that '70s
song in which Sandy and Danny-
(buzzer dings)
- Oh!
- [Lord] Wilmer?
- "Tell Me More".
- No!
(buzzer buzzes)
- [Lord] That is incorrect.
(Kelly screams)
(audience groans)
♪ Ah summer ♪
There's so many songs from that
so keep asking the question.
- [Lord] Sandy and Danny told one another
that they desired the other person.
- Oh, that's, oh God.
There's so many songs in that soundtrack.
- [Wilmer] Wasn't it-
- I'm gonna say like the um...
♪ Summer lovin' had me a blast ♪
Isn't it "Summer Loving"?
(buzzer buzzes)
- [Lord] It is not "Summer Loving".
- "Hopelessly Devoted to You".
- [Lord] I just wanna see, keep-
- Hand Jive!
- [Lord] There you go.
(everyone laughs)
- [Lord] No, it's "You're
The One That I Want".
♪ You're the one that I want ♪
- The One That I Want
- Oh my god, we're losers.
- [Lord] John Travolta
and Olivia Newton-John.
(Kelly laughs)
- It's "The One That I Want".
(audience clapping)
(air horn blaring)
- [Lord] And that's the end of our game.
Kelly you're the winner.
- I literally guessed every song.
(audience cheering)
(triumphant music)
- [Lord] Bring out those talents.
- That was a sad win
for me, Lord. (chuckles)
I can't believe we didn't think of
"You're The One That I Want"!
- Honestly, I felt like
that was the easiest one.
- And I literally said
like three other songs
on the soundtrack.
It's fine.
Okay, well that means that I won, so.
(audience cheering)
I had no idea I was gonna win that.
I was not great at that.
- [Wilmer] Oh man.
- But y'all know the deal.
Everyone here is a winner
on the Kelly Clarkson show,
and Bruvi-
(audience cheers)
is the new breakthrough brewer
that completely re-imagines
the single serve coffee experience
with a remarkably tastier coffee.
The ability to brew seven
different beverages,
eco-conscious bee-pods, which is awesome.
And it looks great on
your kitchen counter.
So get ready, you're all getting one.
(audience cheers)
The audience is all going
home with a Bruvi bundle.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Watch "NCIS" Mondays on CBS.